oh my god you look like a smurf hey guys
what's up this wasn't supposed to be a
video I literally just whipped out my
phone what happened was I've had a
jew-fro for basically my entire life
today I went to get a haircut decided to
do something new and now I'm literally
too scared to walk into the office now
I'm not a shy person or anything like
I've literally come to the office
wearing nothing but body paint for some
reason my hair is something that is
stressing me out like I literally can't
walk into the office right now I'm gonna
have my buddy a day who's gonna bring me
a hat so I can cover my hair and then
see what people think of my new hair
it's it's it's different I look very
different I'm waiting for a day right
now and this is awkward I look weird
with that I look like a weird like sperm
like a fetus okay so I got my friend to
record me I'm gonna walk around the
office and sue people think of this new
haircut
[Music]
what's up I need your help okay you have
good hair yes you love it
okay okay did you do something to your
hair did you think I needed a haircut
yes I looked awful okay Brenda what do
you usually think of when you think of
my hair I always think curly pretty
healthy very cute so weird oh yeah
you're here
have you seen it is Oh cute yeah every
girl loves curls I want you here 100%
honest feedback on this new hairstyle
okay all right close your eyes
good all right
three two one oh no dude no top knots or
so 2016 what is that what you're gonna
do with your head yeah
this the mic you're gonna walk around
with that whatever I'm not even a real
top fun like why is it like weird like
supposed to be I don't know how to do it
I feel like a Viking or something a baby
baby my ponytail still hasn't gone
through puberty you know it's still like
it's a micro ponytail is the ariana
grande look for me right yep the bun
everyone loves ariana grande I'm not a
human no please go back to the curls
what do i do I can't go back to the girl
I hate you can't it's over yeah I don't
like it I think it takes away from what
makes you you
[Music]
thank you I'm gonna go home now and cry
and high-five myself I didn't know just
don't wave goodbye so what do I do
what's your advice it cuz I can't I
can't walk around the office like this
you have heard of extensions like a full
ponytail yeah how long would it take to
grow it out if I had to give an educated
guess seven to eight weeks to get like
another couple inches that seems like
what my doctor used to tell me I could
dye the rest of my hair gray sure so it
looks like a bomb so this is like the
wool whisk that you like you know and
it's commentary on today's society so
keep this right
embrace it listen that's my barber said
this morning I would cut it just cut it
off shut up you do not want me to cut
you I need you to just cut it off
immediately look at me in the eyes and
tell me to cut it out can you take that
out I don't know what happens
[Music]
I am really concerned he looks like one
of those troll dolls I love that this is
on him is it not the same that's so not
cool Eric go back at your money this is
so bad it's so bad I'm sorry
you know I'm honest I Campbell at you
you look like right like that Jesus
Christ
I still have the Jew fro on top okay it
never went away I just don't have the
Jew from society help me
I mean maybe something like this is this
good
usually these videos have some sort of
like positive ending like I've learned
to love you know my hair and I've
learned to love what I have what I
learned is I don't know what the lesson
is I don't know you know what I've
always wanted a mohawk as a kid and now
I've tried it so check that off the
bucket list look how it's moving like a
living it's like jello on my hair or
like a freaking fish wobbling up there
I'm not scared to do anything in my hair
anymore
you can try whatever you want and even
if you fail as majorly as this it
literally does not matter
there's always time to explore discover
who you are and have fun with it let me
know in the comments below if you've
ever tried anything new with your style
or hair and it went terribly wrong
hey unsolved is on a new channel
fingerprint subscribe here that was my
[Music]